this morning CBS News has learned that
President Trump was advised not to
congratulate Russian President Vladimir
Putin on winning his country's election
mr. Trump did so anyway their phone call
yesterday did not include other issues
like Russian election meddling recent US
sanctions and the suspected poisoning of
a former Russian spy and his daughter
chip Reid is at the White House chip
good morning
good morning the State Department is
standing by a report that the Russian
election restricted fundamental freedoms
the president's called a Putin comes as
the White House is considering a plan to
expel Russian diplomats following the
poisoning of a former spy in the UK we
had a very good call
president Trump spoke with the Russian
president Tuesday and offered him well
wishes on getting reelected to a fourth
term in six more years I had a call with
President Putin and congratulated him on
the victory but CBS News has learned
that mr. Trump's advisers warned him
explicitly not to congratulate Putin
most international observers consider it
a rigged election calling him wouldn't
have been hala malas Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell was one of several
Republicans to criticize the president
when I look at a Russian election you
know what I see is the lack of
credibility Arizona Republican John
McCain said an American president does
not lead the free world by
congratulating dictators on winning sham
elections the Russian government was
looking for the vulnerabilities in our
election system on the same day the
Senate Intelligence Committee
recommended ways to improve election
security White House press secretary
Sarah sander said the president did not
raise the issue of Russian interference
in the election with Putin I don't
believe it came up on this specific call
nor did he mention the recent poisoning
of a former Russian spy in England
widely attributed to Moscow I don't
believe that was discussed in today's
call mr. Trump's aides had suggested he
mentioned both issues according to the
Washington Post but it's clear to me
we're not sending the right message to
Putin South Carolina Republican Lindsey
Graham said the omissions were
disappointing every time he talked to
Putin and you give him a pass that
emboldened him President Trump is not
the only world leader to congratulate
Putin the head of the European Union
also
congratulated him and did not mention
the u.k poisoning President Trump says
he'll be meeting with Putin in the
not-too-distant future but the White
House says no date is set John
chip Thanks you know it's rare for a
president to disregard his aides so
thoroughly as he did and what it leads
to is a bad workplace environment which
is why you now see all of this leaking
coming from the president's own team
what does that say John that they're
leaking and it's coming so quickly about
something that's so private well what
happens is you get frustrated as a
staffer yeah and if you feel like your
president's not listening to you go talk
to somebody who will listen to you which
is a ready reporter and that's why you
get these constant stories of infighting
it's not a good situation